thank you for calling into the david
pakman show
please do not use speakerphone have your
question ready
and listen for david to call out your
area code
okay larry your connection is is one of
the worst we've had
uh you're not talking into the phone
through like a crinkled piece of paper
are you
no no i was just uh moving around all
right so eric listen something's going
on with your phone every third word it
sounds like you're under water
is that is there anything we might be
able to do about that
great and we're not on speakerphone are
we and uh
no okay and whatever's on in the
background if you are able to turn it
down it would be really great
yeah all right well what's going on uh i
actually still have a phone number from
new jersey but i currently live in
philadelphia pennsylvania
all right that's still allowed hey i'm
surprised you
still remember me we have caller id so i
have copious notes about you
nathan listen i'm going to let you go
because it does sound like you're
underwater and i don't know what's
causing that but i do appreciate the
phone call and i look forward to
welcoming you
uh back on the program once again in the
future to know your idea
ernesto speaker phone or bluetooth
because your connection is abhorrent
john let me interrupt for a second i
don't know what you're talking about and
it sounds like you're pressing f
i'm curious are are you doing something
else in addition to doing this
call right now no i'm just sitting at my
kitchen i'm just nervous i guess great
your your
audio level is going up and down like
crazy so if you can do something to just
even it out that would be really great
all right one second let me try to fix
it
can you hear me better yeah i'm curious
what did you do that we can just all of
a sudden hear you so well
well i wasn't i wasn't on speaker but
you you bring up a good point keith and
there it sounds like buttons are being
pressed and there's a weird audio thing
so i'm going to let you go but very well
made point
yes it sounds like you're both on
speaker and at a bowling alley can you
hear me at all
okay brad uh deal with the roaches and
call back
um certainly an unusual phone call
david you know what you're annoying i'm
hanging up on you okay
thank you well right
cool well thank you
thank you all right alan uh you might
have us muted because we can't hear you
but you are on if you unmute we might be
able to hear you otherwise i'll have to
move on
hello that's you hey carlton now let me
ask you
what kind of device are we on are we on
some kind of headset or speakerphone
um i'm hooked up to my car right now i'm
just driving back from work
gotcha okay it's it's pretty atrocious
but we'll try to deal with it what's uh
what's your question today
i couldn't hear your name and we can
barely hear you so let's see what we can
do about
um either your connection or your phone
or something
i'm not on speakers so hopefully you can
hear me
okay that's a little better what was
your name my last call
sorry hold on hold on we can we've got
you we've got your volume
at the max and i can still barely hear
you you said something about a jimmy
uh no i just wanted to apologize yes it
is where are you calling from
well actually the phone number is
located in poland but i'm actually
calling from ukraine how dare you call
from a different place than your phone
number that is horrible
account tax asset okay hold on a second
donna let me let me
back up because you're shot out of a
cannon today did you say this is austin
from boston
no oscar oh oscar from okay good oscar
if we're on any kind of device that
might make it harder for me to hear you
please get off of that device because
we've got you maxed out and your level
is very very low
is that better that is much better yeah
historically has been a tough area code
for
i don't know it it sounds like you're
talking through a pillow you you've now
given me like 12 different
sets of requirements and ifs ands and
butts like i
i i would rethink this and call back
okay i got a lot of people holding but
what you're saying is not making sense i
disagree with the premise and i just
can you hear me all right you know i can
hear you extremely well
anyway here's someone who called in i
guess trying to just
spite me about being on speaker phone
david i'm on speaker okay sorry so
you've got a terrible signal i i didn't
hear your name did you say it was
barry yes it's barry i'm sorry can you
hear me better
oh we're not on speaker or bluetooth are
we
oh we're on bluetooth we are thank you
all okay yes
let's let's not do the bluetooth thing
today please okay
all right we'll put you into our system
as barry bluetooth thank you
i can hear you so well yeah who's this
and i'm not like asking
you sound like you're underwater and i
didn't catch your name and i can barely
hear you so let's let's talk through it
what's your name
uh my name is uh okay all right
very good tell me once more what your
question is and please if we're on
speaker or bluetooth take us off because
you sound like you're underwater
hey just one question what do you think
of me do you like me
sorry what do i think of what
what do i think of what
like a moon what do i think of memes
yeah okay so let me see if i understand
john and in the meantime
if you do have us on speaker or are
using bluetooth
please take a second um i have yeah i
have headphones so let me take a
second okay yeah now we've we've updated
that message when you call in telling
people don't do this stuff because we
can't hear a word you're saying
all right andy we can barely hear you
and please tell me we're not on
speakerphone
hello
hello hello can you hear me yeah you cut
out there
sorry uh i must be a problem with my
phone uh so
what i was gonna you're cutting out
again
obviously you want
okay and with that pop we we lost cancer
all right i i'm trying to have a
conversation with you but you're just
not allowing me to
and i am out of time so i'm gonna let
you go i i do appreciate the call but
i would love to be able to have more of
a conversation with you hi
yes we've got you turned up as loud as
you'll go and i can still barely hear
you so what what might we be able to do
um is that better that that is better
yes
awesome great we're having uh somewhat
of a bad connection so
uh i i'm glad you got through and if you
can get to an area where your signal's
better that would be great but what's on
your mind today
from boston how you doing good good and
we're i don't know what's going on in
the background if you're bowling or
something but if we are on speaker
please do take us off
and uh you can go right ahead it sounds
crazy in there
i'm using a headset thank you well let's
just start with if you can tell us your
name that would be great if we're on
some kind of speaker please do take us
off
how are you good are we we're not on
speakerphone are we
no oh boy all right go ahead all right
rome thank you please
let's see if next time we can get a
better connection because you i love
what you're saying but i just i'm having
a hard time here
all right everybody we are live and we
are standing by
for a really important announcement from
president joe biden the cdc
just announcing moments ago vaccinated
people do not need to wear masks
outdoors unless it is impossible to
maintain a safe distance from people
around you and that is where we are
it is very very good news many states
following very closely behind for
example massachusetts will relax
outdoor face mask mandates starting this
friday
with basically an august first date
of ending uh just about everything other
than maybe indoor masking so
some really strong announcements i've
been saying
for some time i'm wearing my mask
outdoors but basically to avoid
social judgment all the evidence i've
seen is that
it is not um medically indicated
and uh i'm just gonna be on the team but
i'm glad that now to be on the team
i will no longer need to wear a mask
outdoors so i do plan
uh on emerging from my house
maskless like the heroic and principled
donald trump when he returned to the
white house after having coveted for
completely irresponsible behavior for
months
with the difference that i've not been
behaving irresponsibly for months so
that's basically the announcement
very exciting and we'll be hearing the
details from joe biden very very soon
and
i look forward to that i have so many
different things to talk about with you
guys today
a few super chats alex kepcke asking
what site i used to look at vaccination
i've been using the new york times site
we can even pull it up briefly new york
times vaccine doses
uh whoa tucker carlson out of nowhere
this is the site i use
and it tracks day-to-day vaccinations
they've been declining we've been
talking about why on the show
and a lot of uh a lot of other important
data available on that website
is the david pakman show about american
politics for anyone or about politics
but for americans
i ask because gates is such a feature
versus ukraine or navalny
i think we did one story on gates last
week and none this week
but this is a show mostly about american
politics
the vegan villaness says my dad has had
coveted for three months and is in the
hospital with covet pneumonia
he got it from an anti-massacre at work
back in late
january yes that is that is bad
that is very very bad um
let's hope for for continued improvement
and recovery
kelsey says david today is my birthday
can i get a shout out yes kelsey happy
birthday thank you
s says vaccinated people really
shouldn't wear masks well it's not about
shouldn't
it's there doesn't seem to be any
advantage to doing it outdoors
um and you know i know that a lot of
people are mad about this announcement
saying no you can still transmit
vaccinated or
you could still get it pre-vaccination
the estimate is one out of a thousand
cases were transmitted outdoors
and that's like people crowded together
like idiots there's no known cases of
like
jogging by someone and getting the virus
and
vaccinated people transmit at a 91
percent lower level
so um you know it's so it's sort of like
if if vaccinated people still need to
wear masks outdoors
no one should ever leave the house
during flu season because
you're talking about you know risks that
are that are down
below that level when you were talking
about vaccinated and outdoors
i think we just have to understand the
science we've got to wear the masks
indoors indoors
we're learning more about even 12 feet
away or 18 feet away you can still
transmit indoors without masks
mostly dependent on the ventilation
system so you've got to keep wearing the
masks indoors
um the science doesn't say
that outdoors is is remotely similar
uh okay what else do we have i'm sure
you've covered it in the show but
thoughts on census
census talk is on today's bonus show so
check out today's bonus show for that
have i seen josh hawley hilariously hawk
his book slamming amazon but selling it
on amazon
yeah he's pathetic i also read that mike
pillow
attacked amazon but then his his new
social media platform
runs on amazon servers maybe somebody
can confirm that
trump is the weapon putin used to attack
the us republicans were the delivery
vehicle
challenge everything even plant-based
beer or these minor issues will again
help turn fox oan viewers
into putin puppets well said
well said um
okay let me say some thank yous astro
lycos has just gifted a sub on twitch
the freak has signed up for 14 months
um also a big thank you to
tapson for the sub um
unlikely gamer has subbed that's four
texas bear claw is five
freudinger is six battle star
catalactica is seven dranoa
is eight and it's me john b has
subscribed and his new
uh subscriber number nine really
appreciate that guys
also a huge thank you to somebody very
special
jake linder just signed up at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code
immoral21 that is an immorally
cheap discount code jake linder
you are new member number 10 today very
much appreciate that jake
um update on okay let's go through what
people are
asking me for unban requests
let me see if i have any unban requests
to adjudicate
i do not i have no unban requests to
adjudicate
midnight club will you talk about
bitclout you mentioned last week it
feels like a scam there's no way to
remove your money from it
yeah so i i mentioned bitclout twice i'm
on it
um supposedly there are multiple
uh exchanges going live in the next week
and um money will be able to come out i
have nothing to do with the platform
we're on it like we're on odyssey and
steemit
and hive and other platforms um
i i think it's been 11 days since i
mentioned it
so i don't have too much else to say
about it it's not like a big
topic per se um
okay no unban requests oh graffiti
so we have more graffiti pacman graffiti
spotted
uh we now have five instances of my last
name being tagged in different places i
would
never suggest to anybody that they do
this if it's in violation of local law
i'm just telling you that more and more
of my last name is popping up graffitied
this is number one here's the second one
this one is in
oakland here's the third one this one is
also in oakland if i recall correctly
there's now a fourth pacman graffiti
this looks like someone just added it to
a pre-existing
graffiti element this is the fourth one
heretofore
unpublished on the david pakman show and
i also now have a
fifth graffiti instance this one
quite nicely done actually uh let's see
whoa hold on a second
there it is so there are now five
graffiti elements with my last name that
we're aware of around
around the united states so keep those
coming in
oakland is representing really strongly
on the graffiti just a lot of these are
on
a lot of these are in oakland which is
super exciting
the pentagon transferred 175 million ip
addresses to a florida company minutes
before trump left office
yeah i don't really get what it means i
read the stories about it
and it's weird i just don't understand
what what is what are we supposed to
what is it what is the meaning of it if
someone can email me
what not just a news article about the
ip address thing but just
what it means i would cover it on the
show
yo yoisho says isn't bernie more
communist than socialist since he
believes in a government
uh no socialists would be socializing
the means of production
among the people communism typically
means government actually owns the
businesses
bernie as far as i know doesn't support
either of those
so there's certainly confusion there's
certainly confusion
i want to say thank you to theo rex as
well as upstairs humor
for their new twitch subs subscribers 11
and 12 today
also a big thank you to erica paulin
erica paulin has just signed up at
joinpakman.com
using the coupon code better21
and with total peace and love erica i
love that you use that coupon code
just remember kids you can also use the
secret coupon code
immoral 21 which is a great code
a really really great code let's take a
look at
tucker carlson's anti-mask rant
yesterday
it's very aggressive now there is a
kernel of logic in it
but then there's a lot of nonsense we
covered this on the broadcast show but i
want to look at it today
we did give in this grotesque version of
halloween went on for more than a year
and it's still going on
not even tony fauci still pretends that
mass are medically
necessary instead mass are purely a sign
of political obedience like kim il-sung
pins in pyongyang
we wear them because we have to the only
people who wear masks voluntarily
outside are zealots
and neurotics how neurotic are they well
we know
a pew survey from last march found that
64
of white americans who classify
themselves as liberal or very liberal
have been diagnosed with an actual
mental health condition now that's
really deceptive for a bunch of reasons
first of all he's only telling us the
percentage of self-identified liberals
who have been diagnosed with a mental
health condition
now one way to avoid diagnosis is simply
never go to a doctor
so if you develop a culture of don't
ever go to a doctor
for a mental health condition then you
hold down the percentage diagnosed he
doesn't give us that information
number two uh if you just have lack of
access to care
and we know that that's the case in many
conservative areas you hold down the
diagnosis level and then number three
just
having anxiety would count as a mental
health condition it's a trash
statement it's the type of statement
where we we just put it directly into
the trash
what he's right about is that there has
been a lot of outdoor mask wearing in
situations where it really doesn't make
scientific sense
merely to avoid judgment and i admit
that i do that
i've been doing it now we are getting
away from masks outdoors
when i walk around on a and someone
passes me on a sidewalk and they're
wearing their mask
i put my mask on not because i think
there's a medical reason to do it i do
it just to be a team player
so there's like a kernel of something
there and the cdc is reacting to that
but then he's just increasing stigma
about mental health he's doing a lot of
garbage here
and you see them everywhere when you
walk down the street in any major city
if you dare to go on foot from union
station to the capitol for example in
washington without wearing a mask
angry biden voters will snort at you in
judgment
again there is this staring down of
people without masks
and you know earlier in the pandemic
before i realized how much i would be
judged for not wearing one outside
i biked without a mask once and and a
couple people
you know gave me dirty looks we now know
nobody's getting it in that situation we
kind of knew it all along
they're saying from behind the gauze how
could you
that's the question we should be asking
of them in return
the rest of us should be snorting at
them first they're the aggressors
it's our job to brush them back and
restore the society we were born in
so the next time you see someone in a
mask on the sidewalk or on the bike path
do not hesitate
ask politely but firmly would you please
take off your mask
that's just idiotic right so the cdc
guidelines which joe biden will
momentarily announce and let's see if we
have uh audio okay
we don't we don't yet but good um are
that vaccinated people don't need to
wear masks outdoors
um why do i care if someone else wears a
mask
the example i gave on the podcast today
is if it's the middle of summer and it's
90 degrees out
and someone passes me wearing a winter
hat i don't think it's necessary
i think it's odd but maybe they have a
medical condition where their head gets
cold even in summer
maybe they just like the way it looks
why do i care what they're doing
right so this is where it starts to go
completely off the rails
science shows there is no reason for you
to be wearing it your mask
is making me uncomfortable stupid we
should do that and we should keep doing
it until wearing a mask
outside is roughly as socially accepted
as lighting a marble in an elevator
it's repulsive don't do it around other
people it's not because again right
lighting a marlboro
in an elevator and we have a live video
here
lighting a marlboro in an elevator
actually impacts
other people whereas just wearing a mask
doesn't impact me other people wearing
masks i don't care if they want to do it
go ahead and do it
that's the message we should send
because it's true as for forcing
children to wear mass
outside that should be illegal right
your response when you see children
wearing masses
what's more illegal a child wearing a
mask or my discount codes
play should be no different from your
response to seeing someone beat a kid in
walmart
call the police immediately now it
should be different your response should
be different
contact child protective services keep
calling until someone arrives
what you're looking at is abuse it's
child abuse and you are morally
obligated to attempt to prevent it
if it's your own children being abused
then act accordingly
let's say your kid's school emailed you
to announce that every day after lunch
your sixth grader was going to get
punched in the face by a teacher
how would you respond to that in a
completely different way than to mask
wearing yeah so anyway there's tucker
and you know he he had a kernel of
something that there would be a lot of
people on the left that would agree with
which is with the mat we don't need to
do the masks outside and we probably
never did and that's what the cdc is
saying
for vaccinated people and on and lots of
states are now saying
nobody has to wear the masks outside
regardless of vaccination unless you're
crowded together great we're on the same
page
um until he goes into
all of this completely bogus and crazy
stuff so there's tucker carlson
and um people suggesting it maybe he's
projecting his own experiences of people
calling him out yeah he probably is
he probably is i don't doubt that
whatsoever if you're just joining us
we're standing by for
joe biden believed to be delivering an
important message
about easing outdoor mask wearing the
cdc just made this announcement about 45
minutes ago
every indication that joe biden is going
to announce the same thing
tomorrow night i hope you will all join
me
for joe biden's first address to a joint
session of congress
tomorrow night at 8 pm eastern the
speech is at 9 i'll be live at 8 and
then if uh
maybe we'll even take phone calls after
so big evening stream tomorrow night
a few other super chats um
let's see here david do you think people
out there who refuse to get the shot
should take advantage would take huge
advantage of this i'll be getting my
second shot on saturday yeah some people
will just lie
listen the people who are refusing to
get the vaccine are probably already not
wearing masks outside so i don't think
it'll be a big change
david will you listen to my song about
prison reform maybe i have a lot on my
plate
i live in a red state they judge me for
wearing a mask i've heard that from
friends in red states
i'd put a second mask on just to piss
them off yeah i just wouldn't engage
i just wouldn't engage when trump
supporters wear maga hats it doesn't
make sense to me
but i don't share my opinion with them
yeah well said ian fraser with a
really strong 50 new zealand dollar
super chat i don't like clothes
please take them off carlson's logic
isn't
it's not logical ferret queen says have
you ever seen the movie contagion they
had special bracelets indicating
vaccination do you think it would have
been useful
i haven't seen it and it seems a little
bit stigmatizing in a way
masks are a no-brainer during flu season
indoors
that may well be yeah shout out to
producer
luis can you correct tony fauci to dr
fauci
can i correct it what do you mean oh
tucker said tony fauci yeah i don't care
about them
um okay other people i need to be
thanking
less qq and more pew pew
has just signed up via twitch so has
angry mob
nasty questions is in for 12 months
those are subscribers 14 15 and 16 today
and i will be thanking in a deep and
sincere way today this is going to be
different very often during the streams
i will insincerely praise people who
sign up on my website
today i will sincerely praise
anybody who takes advantage of either
this coupon code better21
or the secret code immoral21 on my
website
joinpakman.com today only sincere praise
tomorrow night tomorrow night stream i'm
going back to completely
insincere praise of people who sign up
so take advantage of that
uh oh i do have oh i do have an unban
request to adjudicate hold on
here is my gavel when people get
banned on twitch they can request being
unbanned such a user is here
this user created their twitch account
yesterday
they first showed up in my streams today
and immediately sent the message
libtards
they were banned within seconds by our
moderator jaby gatz
and their unban request message is
censorship that is denied
and confirmed permanent
that is a really stupid thing to say and
a
even stupider way to try to get yourself
unbanned the bands are free folks
and we are handing them out like i would
say like candy except it's not i'm not
really
handing out candy at this point
um okay so we did tucker
we did vaccines we did outdoor
masks oh here's some this is just kind
of funny
here's a tick tock user who actually i
believe has quite a following let me see
here
yeah this i don't know who this is this
is ashley with 30
000 tick tock followers big fan of the
show
here's a cat video during which you can
actually hear the podcast playing in the
background let's see if we can listen to
this together
i think i'm pitching membership i think
there's a live stream going on and i'm
pitching membership listen to this
hold on let's make sure we have good
audio on it
membership which i think is as
disgusting as he is
i mentorship pitch which i think
all right so there you go uh a lot going
on
and membership being pitched in real
time i think that
the membership pitch alone is immoral
but the pitch combined with the video is
probably illegal
that's my instinct on that uh you tell
me
oh do i have any more of the anti-trans
woman's voicemails i think i do
yeah here we go one just came in minutes
ago this is fred fresh off the presses
listen to this
hey david um so i wanted to talk to you
about the um abortion issue
because i feel like a lot of like
centralists will do this like weird
thing where it's like
nothing in their itinerary of like
you know their political preferences
goes along with
um you know child support or
helping families along and helping
families you know
develop the tools necessary i don't know
what on earth she's talking about
let's see if i got any others
i think i did but now i'm struggling to
find oh here it is here's another one
hi david this is ashley again um i just
um
so i know that he said that
the situation with um
changing people's
sexuality or whatnot is a sensitive
issue
and i totally agree that maybe i think
she means gender not
sex we haven't talked about people
changing sexuality for a really long
time
i and a lot of other people have been
pretty insensitive
to um you know
okay of future generations of
people who you know
[Music]
from a religious standpoint have the
wrong gender
oh now we're on gender i do believe that
is she using gender and sexuality when
it's someone's a sexuality i assume they
mean sexual orientation right
we should be very sensitive to
um people who do have the wrong genders
and who are given their own gender
and i just believe all right anyway this
person continues to call
so people asked for an update on that
she's continuing to call
i do want to say a big thank you to bent
schroeder
bent schroeder who has just signed up
via joinpacman.com using the coupon code
immoral21 we may wrap the immoral coupon
code tomorrow night if joe biden gives a
good speech tomorrow night we might just
end the coupon code immoral 21 something
to think about
um why not why not
as we stand by for joe biden with a big
mask announcement joe biden is going to
be telling us
we believe that it is not necessary to
wear masks outdoors when vaccinated
which is fantastic
let's look at a few other super chats oh
thanks to rich bird nation for the
twitch sub by the way appreciate that
signing up via twitch prime
brian stark says on chauvin's defense
closing keep in mind every defendant has
the right to zealous representation it
wasn't deranged you know better david
no i brian you're wrong i addressed that
in my video i say
every defendant has the right to
representation
and uh the closing statement from eric
nelson
was deranged in terms of its
relationship to the facts
but i never at any point said that derek
chovin doesn't deserve whatever is the
best defense to get him acquitted it
failed to get him acquitted the defense
not only was deranged it failed guilty
on all counts
but i stand by my uh position on that
pedro says enough deranged voicemails
nobody needs them
all right danny says you missed my last
super chat left is best
let's see danny says do i think there's
any chance for filibuster reform i think
there
is but it's feeling like a very low
priority right now
and i don't believe we will see anything
in 2021
maybe 2022.
um okay
oh hold on i gotta do a ban we just
dropping a banhammer
on twitch wow a lot of peop it's
actually they're out enjoy it must be
is there a full moon they're out in
droves tonight
big thank you to jane gass for signing
up at joinedpakman.com
jane thank you also big thank you to
caitlin bianchi for signing up at
joinedpakman.com bianchi
a very common last name
in argentina where i was born very
common last name
in fact have some family friends last
name bianchi
of course of italian origin but from
from argentina
let's see what else we have here david
curious as to your thoughts on the
current state of u.s taiwan
affairs i think biden is doing a great
job on that front uh i am i am not
displeased with biden so far on taiwan
and i have a segment i'm planning on
that
maybe for thursday maybe for next monday
what was that strange noise
please stand by please okay so we're
about to get started here good
um very very close to starting thanks to
sinful solutions for the super chat
appreciate that
uh the sly witted savage savagery and
the rubber mallet is just perfect
it's actually plastic but i would even
upgrade the mallet
in theory shout out to the old producer
louis
sorry yeah louis not luis although a lot
of people believe it is luis
and they will stand by it they will
stand by it
a big thing lewis actually at one point
was the target of anti-latino
discrimination because people
assumed that by lewis we met luis
and you know he's he's half iranian half
jewish so
scott sherman has just signed up at
jointpakman.com
and scott is new member number 21 thanks
scott
also thank you to
is it gabe or gape horn
gabe horn or gay porn oh god okay i
understand it now that is new member
number 22.
uh i'm gonna go with gabe gabriel horn
gabriel horn do you think biden will
push forward on student debt relief even
just 10k
i do i do i think
oh god people are going crazy clifton
shipped yeah
ladies and gentlemen we got him thoughts
on charlie baker
not bad for a republican
not bad for a republican i guess is what
i would say
people highly highly triggered in the
chat yeah
oh man i hope that we're not gonna
tomorrow night
we are bringing back like the prime time
professional respectable stream the
daytime streams are pretty coarse and
and not respectable
but tomorrow night um joe biden will be
addressing
the nation in his first joint address
before the house and senate we need to
keep it
very clean tomorrow night okay
why does anyone take tucker seriously
especially after his lawsuit in which
his defense was he shouldn't be taken
seriously
very good question millions of people
still do
thanks for being so straightforward with
my last question nice to have someone
who doesn't overexplain this thing
over explain things has biden met
exceeded or underseeded
your hopes so far he's done more than i
thought he has exceeded my expectations
on today's
show this is the podcast this is the
member show this is you know oh whoa
this is all that stuff
i grade joe biden's first hundred days
okay thank you
that's on today's pro podcast yeah you
can get access to that right away
you have missed nothing people coming in
asking if they've missed it we are
waiting for joe biden
joe biden will be delivering remarks
about masking
the cdc just announcing
vaccinated people need not wear masks
outdoors in most situations
i will be following cdc guidelines as i
have
all along okay
thank you to james matunen
who has just signed up on my website
using the secret
unpublished coupon code immoral21
thank you also to what the spock for the
twitch prime
subscription we love that
pacman vs destiny chess subscriber
battle 2021
i would do that if steven kenneth
destiny
bonnell the second wanted to line it up
it can be a bunch of work to line that
up
but i would do a chess sub battle with
destiny if people want to if somebody
wants to help set it up
although i know sometimes when destiny
has people help him
with stuff he ends up out eight grand
so i don't want that to happen but i
would go by that
i would do that in new york city
it's easy to form crowds outdoors given
that why change the guidelines for masks
outdoors
uh you uh i yeah okay i already i
already talked about it
and listen justin if you want to keep
wearing the mask outdoors by all means
do it i am not on tucker's side
where you should ask people to take
masks off
that's really stupid um but the cdc
uh has the science and uh i i would
follow what the cdc says
big thank you to jenna droulette
jenna droulette who just signed up with
the coupon code better21
at joinpakman.com whoa
uh thank you jenna
let's see here yeah a lot of people
saying
if you feel safer wearing a mask outside
do it i completely agree
i absolutely agree
uh okay so we've gotten that
we did this we did oh i have a couple
other
new um stream intros i'm trying
one is like a jessie lee peterson kind
of uh
highlights tell me if you think this
would make a good stream intro video
we are amazing welcome to
to the uh father's day youtube live i'm
jessalyn peterson
apologize for the late start but we are
black and black people are late
we start on cp time i'm glad you're here
you love me
i don't really know you do you have to
know me to love me yeah well i love you
thank you are you surprised not really
were you surprised that i threw you off
the radio show
not really and one of the reasons i'm
concerned about you being a progressive
is that me specifically or all
progressives all men
men only men only men progressive women
don't concern you
it's normal normal abnormal for women to
be progressive
interesting or liberal but it's abnormal
for a man to be
a liberal or progressive is a sign of
being a beta male
i didn't know because real men are
conservative
if i became conservative would i no
longer be beta
you become alpha well something to think
about
do you find that it's difficult for
young men men in your age group to find
good women to date
not at all all right why don't you date
men i'm not attracted to men
oh god but what you consider it might be
a man would you think of it as a man
it would i think of it as a man right
it's a person right i don't say it right
it's a female the children are the lie
the liberal media
the democratic party the writer
republicans the never trumpers
okay uh so like everybody but trump the
hashtag
movement plus you sound mentally off you
know like
like the lights was on but nobody was
home you're making assessments of who's
mentally off on
people on tv but that's how evil
oh they'll destroy you this was like a
40-minute interview cut down
to six which i'm thinking of using as a
stream intro i think it's pretty
nicely done to get what they want and
that's power and well
i'm curious if they're so powerful the
children of the life they're not
powerful
oh that's what they want i think they
will destroy you they will they'll
destroy you they'll try to destroy it oh
okay to get power
do you agree with that no no bringing
that up the reason was you've called me
a girly man so many times
remember that we talked about that oh
okay that's because it's not because i
think you
that i'm gay right got it glad we
clarified you know a lot of people are
sexually assaulted and raped
and they don't come forward and the
reason they don't
you don't believe that that's a made-up
lie too oh who made that up the children
are the laughs
i said children of their lives i
shouldn't have they're doing it because
they hate men
oh and they especially hate straight
white conservative christian men of
power
if it wasn't for them america would be
associated with society already it would
be what a socialist
society uh by getting rid of jobs many
people emotionally took care of people
about getting into
full-time jobs and they had to work two
part-time jobs in order to survive so
you don't even understand the talking
points three obama phones
that's socialism but you're not
answering the question that's the answer
but i don't like the answer you don't
understand the question
i think i understand it uh what is it
about the questions that's difficult for
you
do you would you david pacman believe it
just because she said
i liked how you had to check what my my
last name was there
i would leave it enough to investigate
it yeah
give me just a yes these were the days
so give me a simple yes or no
your friends are watching right now i
hope so and they were watching because
they thought you're going to keep my
butt
so you got to live up to it i found out
this was a debate today
would you believe it are these really
the most important topics for you
absolutely
okay are there others that are more
important for you yeah like
what's up our economic system wealth
inequality healthcare
geopolitics nuclear disarmament climate
change and the black people go into a
trance
and they go in and then you yeah they
they reach for the d
why eating chicken i guarantee you if
they went now
and voted for and asked them to vote for
it they'll go with the homosexuals i
hope so and the democratic party
they have been morally bankrupt well i
don't know home officials have gotten in
there and they corrupt the churches
is there anything else not that i can
think of that's it yeah
amazing people coming from [ __ ]
countries and we don't have no idea who
crossing the borders
uh we can have bin laden folks come in i
think we just disagree
amazing um
it's crazy to disagree isn't it is that
a good thing that the president has done
what did he do do you buy jobs how it
doesn't matter how he's brought them
back is that a good thing
if you're going to claim he did it you
have to explain how is that a good thing
that happened
it talked about too many jobs the
question is what did he do to bring the
jobs
this reminds me of my interview with
that republican strategist two weeks ago
how do you know he did it this is a good
thing that he did i have something to
admit guys
this entire interview was a scripted
skit it wasn't real
can you imagine no really it wasn't it
was actually all too real he like stayed
in character after it was over
jobs are good i'm asking you what trump
did what are you saying yesterday
what is a man i'm sorry what is a man
i do politics not dictionary are you a
man love what is love
i i don't do dictionary definitions i
won't be doing dictionary definitions at
any of my events that's the one thing if
people are expecting that i'm not doing
any dictionary definitions the [ __ ]
so amazing incredible you like [ __ ] i'm
sorry you like
[ __ ] i don't know any have you ever
slept with a slap
i don't think so would you date a [ __ ]
it's a pejorative it's not a term i use
amazing did you have fun no
in in a thousand years when the
sociologists
and the philosophers try to figure out
what exactly happened in the united
states
right around this time right this type
of conversation
is going to be incredibly informative
for them so i'm glad to have
participated in it
good man they're going to say wow jesse
was amazing check out our brand new song
on the uh destiny peterson.com
on my instagram uh you're doing songs
now
facebook twitter facebook twitter you
sing or you play an instagram call
you know what a beta male is no check
out the song
chase trump right alpha
not better anyway so that's a new that's
a possible new stream intro
i think that's i think it's pretty good
um i have one other one
uh oh hold on let me thank a few people
thank you to michael charette
for signing up at joinpackman.com
domingo
payne is a new member at
joinedpakman.com
nicholas klein just signed up and
keen ironheart just signed up putting us
at 29 also thank you on twitch to
dump trump 2020 amy as well as this
is slammin new members 30 and 31 today
i have one other possible stream intro
let me get to a couple of other super
chats
david is there a physical is there a
psychical
mental illness for people taking the
vaccine
my family mind has been losing it in
their head about politicals
i have no idea what that means i have no
idea what that means i'm sorry
have i seen the dissident yet i have not
i would love to see a show starring you
and jesse but you don't deserve that
kind of torture
thank you what happened to jessie lee
peterson after the twitter gay porn
fiasco
love the stream d-man like the stream
everyone pretty good intro might get a
little stagnant though
do you own eth yes and do you think it
can surpass btc
no idea any word on people missing the
second dose in the u.s
one dose 42 percent full 29 seems like a
large void
i think only about eight percent of
people who get a first dose are missing
the second dose is what i read
just signed up using better21 thanks for
the shout out david
and for the amazing content i want to be
part of the pacman community well scott
you now are you now are
so it was staged or you were making a
joke no the the jesse lee peterson
interview was not staged
was not staged co gal
says david saludo de chile mandan
yes thank you very much greetings from
chile
love it okay one other possible stream
intro video from the creationist cat
appearance i did some period of time ago
his name
is david hackman political commentator
left-wing propagandist this one's good
fake news an heir to the pac-man family
fortunes
he gets money from george soros to
promote communism
anti-fall and uh probably baby punching
too
and he's here to spread more of his
anti-american freedom-hating shy-by-line
right david peckman
all right kikka chashi
if you like fake news he's your bro
satan has some communism and current
events too
from his argentinian
it's maybe too aggressive for the show
right is this is this too aggressive
hating donald trump's about all he do
should get ready pack my shoe
is this beneath the show if it is i
won't use it maybe maybe i need to um
like it's too graphic probably for a
nighttime stream like tomorrow night if
we're streaming biden's address
and that's the intro i think it's not
good
but for more like a trashy like middle
of the day stream it might be okay
we'll look at it um okay
david do you think this could possibly
be a predicted end date to the mask
mandate i know some states are ending
their
mandate soon we already know what joe
biden's announcing today 45 minutes ago
the cdc said
vaccinated people don't need to wear
masks outdoors in just about any
situation joe biden is about to
now kind of restate that so this is not
going to be like a full end to
masking but it's going to be mask
related
ryan says an idea that would be fun to
stream with and integrate to videos
guess who board game with prominent
political figures in the current news
cycle
ryan i love you you've been around and
supporting for a while that is a dud
idea i know my audience well enough to
know that
a guess who board game that i play on
stream
that would be i would if i would
immediately hemorrhage
all of my viewers if i did that so ryan
uh
with total peace and love appreciate it
but we're not going to do that
daniel says pfizer's new slogan everyone
deserves a second shot
nice thanks for keeping it 100
got my second dose that's great ken
volkeri says this song is funny but it's
not your of
david i don't know what that means
interesting i want to say thank you to
symbolic gamer as well as grungy dan
for their new twitch subs putting us at
33
also some just absolutely perfect people
to thank
talia smith just signed up on my website
derek haley just signed up on my website
and evan meldrum just signed up at
joinpackman.com
new members 34 35 and 36.
thanks very much guys um
let's see here what else do we have
going
on am i going to talk about biden's
first hundred days yes
on today's podcast i grade biden's first
hundred days
and i go through section by section
economic promises
uh immigration promises covet promises
we go through
everything that's on today's show
david can you please play the friday
chat parody of you speaking spanish
i can't find it oh yeah
let me see that was posted to the
subreddit
how could i find that's tough i'm having
trouble finding that too but that's
really great content
um let's see parody
i think it's parody and it's related to
pedro from colombia um
oh i think i found it yeah here we go
tell me if this is what you were
referring to well
the david pakman show uh is
funded primarily by membership
go to joinpacman.com
coupon code still works
phone fridays suck because
my callers suck oh this might not be it
uh let's actually go now to the phones
let's speak
first to uh pedro from
colombia pedro como
now my spanish is better than this guys
so i don't know
if he just can't speak spanish
or if he's mimicking me speaking spanish
poorly
i don't that i don't understand okay
let's continue
oh mr pacman i got covered
uh i'm not feeling good
uh pedro what part of colombia
are you from de donde eres
now of course being argentinian i say de
donde sos
now i might modulate if i'm speaking to
a colombian
maybe i would say the donaires but
that's not even i mean that's not how i
talk
mr pacman i forgot
you forgot okay muchas gracias pedro
let's go uh next okay yeah
that's pretty good i like that um and by
the way
30 000 people are now subscribed to our
subreddit
i believe that we have the biggest
subreddit for independent media shows
hosted by
left-handed argentinian jews nobody has
as many subscribers as we do
in that group so to speak
okay good we have not missed joe biden
he is running 30 minutes late
he is running 30 minutes late but we
have not missed joe biden
and we are expecting him absolutely any
moment
oh by the way i haven't talked about
this before but i think i will mention
it
trumpists who lost everything you know
they lost the house in 2018
they lost the senate in 2020 they lost
the white house in 2020
they lost their dignity they lost
everything
they have taken to disliking white house
youtube streams
so this is very common where as soon as
there's a new white house stream
a 1500 of them 1600 of them will come in
and dislike it
and what's really funny is that i
actually get emails
voicemails tweets and different things
from viewers
who say david how on earth do you think
biden has 58
approval have you seen the dislikes
on his live streams as if in a country
of 331 million people
1700 dislikes on a video
on youtube tell you anything about the
president i mean it's it's sad more than
anything else but
it's also a sign of of how dumb people
are that they might think that that is
a signal that should be listened to more
so than actual polling
anyway it's it's pathetic uh
let's see here david pat has been doing
a really good job can we give him a
promotion and a raise maybe a co-host
position
no then i'd lose him from the good job
that he's doing you want to have him do
the good job that he's doing
geez uh
is that how you're running your business
fool in the rain by the way fool in the
rain one of my favorite led zeppelin
songs
can you shout out audrey woman and tobin
daisy
sure shout out christian says watch
right wing media claim cdc eased outdoor
mask mandate because of tucker's rant
yeah except it was announced two days
ago that they were going to be doing it
um
david is there a psychical illness when
coming to politics and vaccine
my fam is lost brain matter over these
things with conspiracies
man i'm really i i am so sorry anamoli i
don't i just don't understand what
you're saying
psychical illness when coming to
politics and vaccine
man i don't know maybe
greetings from a cuban who lives in
miami nice
greetings um can we get louis on a
stream in the future
maybe fooling the rain drum cover at 2
million subs please
i would consider doing that a fool in
the rain
i believe that that's uh that song is in
12 8 i believe
the great john bonham you know who does
a really good let me see there's this
great drum video
full in the rain drums
who was it that did it really well and
actually explains it
i think it might have been the late
great jeff porcaro actually
uh
yeah i don't know there's one that's
like really well explained not finding
it though
yeah anyway sorry about that okay sorry
for the distraction there
we are yes nobody's missed it i know
peop some people are getting uh
upset that we've somehow missed the
biden thing or you've missed it
he's running 30 minutes late
it's uh it's it's wild what is going on
uh 30 minutes late at this point crazy
interview intro is good but agree with
stagnant comment after watching three
times it'll be old need very powerful
quick
cuts well you know the other one i have
that's a that's a candidate
for the stream intros is producer pat's
video of trump's most humiliating
moments
i just don't know about q anon you do
know
i don't know no i don't know you know if
you go out and you want to buy groceries
you need
a picture on a card you need id
he wants to host next year's g7 summit
at his
own doral golf club take care of the
floors you know the floors of the forest
it's very important
frederick douglass is an example of
somebody who's done an amazing job and
is being recognized more and more i
noticed
ivanka trump the president's daughter is
sitting in
for the secretary of state
remember that incredible night with the
maps
and the republicans are red and that map
was so red from
chin tendulker to
the new york times they are a true enemy
of the people
i think we have enough of an interview
here hope okay that's enough
let's go this russian bounty story we
have multiple
we actually didn't even get all of them
in this like that's what's crazy
just saying that trump knew all along i
was there for a tiny
little short period of time it was much
more for an inspection there was no
problem during the day
and said quote crazy joe biden he
doesn't know me
but he would go down fast and hard
crying
all the way they'll go out and they'll
vote and they're gonna have to go and
check their vote by going to the poll
and voting that way
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
as opposed to once the state department
is emphasizing to world leaders
that they should stay at donald trump's
hotels and they say the noise causes
cancer you tell me that one okay
all right trump ordered robert mueller
the special prosecutor
be fired the factory policy is
at all times and trump puts on goggles
but no mask
and we're building a wall in colorado
we're building a beautiful wall trump
floated the idea
of swapping puerto rico greenland
the ramp that i descended after my west
point commencement speech was very long
and steep
had no handrail and most importantly was
very slippery
our army manned the air it ran
the ramparts it took over the airports
it did everything it had to do
wherever trump goes he tries to make
himself seem dominant over whoever he's
shaking hands with trump's
strong strong-looking situation room
photo was a staged
photograph likely taken hours after the
event
lock them up you should lock them up
lock up the buttons lock up hillary i
too have a nuclear button
but it is a much bigger and more
powerful one than his
yeah this is our oscars i think honestly
the oscars have been such a disaster
i think this would have gotten better
ratings than what they actually got on
sunday
the narcissist in chief donald trump
wanted his signature
printed on all of the checks
he's not reading a presidential daily
briefing
that has been dumbed down to one page
mostly pictures graphs and maps get that
son of a [ __ ] off the field
right now out he's fired
he's fired so in florida
i encourage all to request a ballot and
vote by mail
the win direction shifted and it sort of
split his hair sort of back to front
trump was
laughed at by the entire room of world
leaders
oh by the way when i say the oscars were
a disaster i just mean the ratings are
down like 75
like no one's watching i i didn't mean
anything about i haven't watched them in
a decade i don't know
that anything happened that was or
wasn't interesting i just mean
the ratings are down so much united
nations one of the wettest we've ever
seen from the standpoint
of water water then they did dumps they
call them dumps big massive dumps
lavar ball is unaccepting of what i did
for his son
i should have left them in jail these
aren't people
these are animals the same vaccine could
not work you take
a solid flu vaccine you don't think that
would have an impact or might have an
impact on corona
no cummings district is a disgusting rat
and rodent infested
mess here we go
compared to other presidents has gone
more oh it's too much
modern president cnn should be ashamed
of itself
having you working for them you are a
rude
terrible person trump showed up and
started throwing
paper towels to people like he was
shooting free throws
in basketball donald trump's decision to
do the corona caravan drive
around walter reed well it's not the
hardest task no but it has a picture and
it's the last one
and it's an elephant no no you see
that's all misrepresentation well
the white house had put together a
statement praising mccain and his life
and his heroism
trump said no no statement i'll post a
tweet instead
this is the guy who stared directly
at the solar eclipse oh boy always play
it down
anyway okay i'm not gonna play the whole
thing but that's another candidate
for the um for some stream intro videos
and we're working on other things we
have a lot of different things
upcoming that we are uh that we are
working on as we stand by
for joe biden with a really strong
announcement
on masking masking i want to get this
announcement done so that i can go
outside with no mask
that's why i'm standing by here for it
okay all right
a few other super chats based biden from
norway
trey says as someone who works at a
theme park do you think this new
guidance
helps or creates a blurry line as to
which outside venues to mask up for
it says that any venue that still has a
mask guideline uh
goes so i would assume theme parks
um will just continue having mask
guidelines
did you see the republican person claim
democrats were cultists
i don't know who said it but i saw fox
news quote them i have not seen that
no steven says that that video of
trump's worst hundred moments
almost makes him nostalgic a horror
comedy yeah it's
really a comedy of errors and
humiliations
quite frankly i want to say thank you to
theodore
koblewski who just signed up at
joinpackman.com and his new member
number 37 today
also big thank you to christina for the
win
as well as henry ton
coffee nub weather boxer
putting us at 41. oh so you know since
we have time
i've had this for so long on my agenda
to look at during this
that was weird strange where'd that
noise come from i had this on my agenda
to look at during an inter during a live
stream
somebody reminded me of my old interview
with charles butler
and uh it's actually pretty damn funny
let me show you guys this this is an old
classic
we're not gonna miss the biden event
this is from
the old days okay this is just an old
classic
interview let's take a look at it it is
quite fun i'm joined today by charles
butler he is a nationally syndicated
talk show host
also a financial advisor charles it's
really great to have you on i've been
listening to your program i listened to
the december 11th show
that show was a doozy you were
responding to the senate torture report
you had a lot to say and one thing that
caught my
ear and and that's kind of where i want
to start today is
you thought that senator dianne
feinstein from california
should be punched why why did you come
to that conclusion
well you know she her the only reason
that she released that port
that report was for political reasons
and unfortunately david we have too many
people who are grandstanding
uh and playing with people's lives she
has endangered the lives of real
citizens
of real patriots uh dr mitchell said
he's received death threats
you know these people do not play we
know that al qaeda
osama bin laden and his like to tell
this goes off the rails they are killing
americans
these people are receiving death threats
because of her
unclassifying information and that's why
the cia has always sought
to hide information from congress
because of people like diane von
so you're saying you're okay with the
report
that said that the cia was lying about
the extent to which they were using
these techniques because you think it's
the right thing to do to hide that
no i don't think it's the right thing to
do to hide that but i don't think it's
anyone's business
outside of its classified information
what we do
and the facts are uh talking to all the
people who were involved
in on the cia side is that they briefed
congress they briefed feinstein they
briefed
rockefeller they briefed all these
democrats the republicans
also said that they were brief uh so
feinstein and the democrats are
blatantly lying
so you said that dianne feinstein should
be punched what other circumstances
uh do you advocate physical violence
against women
i don't you know i don't make that
distinction about women and
violence thing that's kind of a european
you know uh
chivalry thing and at the end of the day
oh
uh it's bs because women are out here
fighting men
you see it you see it in in the movies
today uh where
women are attacking men and like that
video with ray rice
his wife clearly came back across the
elevator with her fist balled up
and he had a reaction he didn't punch it
once or twice
he just just stuck out his fist and jab
to keep her off of me all right but so
but
but without getting on to that so you're
comfortable in other words advocating
physical violence against dianne
feinstein who happens to be a woman
i don't care who she is if she's in the
kitchen
and she needs to play the game and at
the end of the day what dianne
feinstein's done
a punches is the minimum uh that
that that should happen to her but this
woman
because she's a senator she
has said that she wants to um
uh she well she's going to get people
killed
so when you compare a punch to getting
people killed david you know you can
play that game no it's no game i'm just
trying to figure out what your level
of comfort is advocating for violence my
level of comfort is simply this
right uh uh it's not advocating you're
putting words in my mouth i'm not
advocating anything
well you said she should be punched
presumably someone should do that
punched her right in her face yeah they
put these women they put these women in
positions of
responsibility and it's great this guy's
this disappeared right and of power
and what does she do she's playing games
with people's lives
yeah and you used you used that term
these women and i know you've said we
should actually have
fewer women in the senate so why
why should we have fewer women and just
so the audience knows women make up
slightly more than 50 percent of the
population they make up 20
of the senate you think there's too many
women in the senate why is that
now let me ask you this now charles
before you go into that let me just
make sure my question is clear you just
said
you don't make recommendations or
statements based on gender in other
words
you don't care whether you're saying a
woman or man deserves to be punched you
don't care about gender but at the same
time you're saying
there should be fewer women in the
senate so you are actually concerned
with gender right
that's because dianne feinstein
he doesn't even understand the double
standard well do your research
david which i'm sure you'll do uh dianne
feinstein
came out this summer and said that we
need more women in the senate
because we're more collegial we get
illegible
that was dianne feinstein who said that
not charles butler well but there are
there are actual studies that show that
women do have a tendency
to build rapport and work together and
and that that's actually based in
science though
that's not that's bs at the end of the
day this country and the world
has worked perfectly well with men doing
what they need to do and working
together and there's no other
uh there's no other place than the
military that i look at
where men get together work very
effectively together in an all-male
environment without the female influence
so you discount those studies
totally okay and on what basis have you
decide how when you see that
how do you decide when a study is valid
and when it isn't is it just based on
your preconceived notions
no because of the people because of the
people doing the studies when you have
these girly men
right sitting back doing studies like uh
well we need women
on the football field and we need women
doing
this and we we don't need women doing
anything bottom line
they're i think we've got biden
i'll be leaning out the path ahead here
we go to continue our fight against
cover 19
big big announcements to july 4th
this our target date to get life in
america closer to normal
and began to celebrate our independence
from the virus
together with our friends and our loved
ones as we celebrate independence day
right but before that i wanted to speak
briefly to all of you today about the
recent
change announced by the center for
disease control here we go
cdc let me say first
while we still have a long way to go in
this fight
and a lot of work to do in may and june
to get us to july 4th
we've made stunning progress because of
all of you the american people
cases and deaths are down down
dramatically
from where they were when i took office
in january 20th
and continuing to fall this is
particularly true
for a group of americans that we were
most worried about
when it came to the virus senior
citizens when i took office in january
we were losing literally tens of
thousands of our seniors
each week grandparents who were loved so
dearly
moms and dads pillars of every community
gone by the thousands every day
at that time less than one percent
of seniors were fully vaccinated when i
took office
right today in less than 100 days
more than 67 percent two-thirds of
our seniors are now fully vaccinated
and more than 80 percent of our seniors
have had at least one shot
stunning that effort resulted in a drop
of 80 percent in deaths among american
seniors
a 70 percent drop in hospitalizations
so instead of losing thousands of
seniors
each day we're saving thousands of lives
and more
and more as each day goes by
and by the way based on reported data
the proportion the proportion of seniors
who've been vaccinated
is essentially equal between white
and seniors of color i said from the
beginning
that we were we're going to fight this
virus with
equity equity for all as a matter of
fact if i'm not mistaken
there are more latinos and
african-american seniors
that have been vaccinated as a
percentage than white seniors
these numbers are a sign of progress on
that front as well
now last week i announced that we had
crossed the threshold
of 200 million shots
we've now since inauguration day
we have given 215
million shots and that
anyone 16 years of age or older is now
eligible to get the vaccine
now today immediately go get it and
because of the extraordinary progress
we've made in fighting this virus
and the progress our scientists have
made in learning about
how it gets transmitted earlier today
the cdc made an important announcement
here we go
starting today if you're fully
vaccinated
and you're outdoors you need and not in
a big crowd
you no longer need to wear a mask
absolutely clear love it if you're in a
crowd like a stadium or at a conference
or a concert you still
need to wear a mask even if you're
outside
but beginning today gathering with a
group of friends
in a park going for a picnic
as long as you are vaccinated and
outdoors right you can do it without a
mask
the cdc is able to make this
announcement
because our scientists are convinced by
the data
that the odds of getting or giving the
virus to others
is very very low if you're both been
fully vaccinated
and out in the open air indeed the cdc
also clarify which outdoor activities
are safer
or less safe depending on whether you've
been vaccinated
the bottom line is clear if you're
vaccinated
you can do more things more safely
both outdoors as well as indoors love it
for so for those who haven't gotten
their vaccination yet
especially if you're younger or think
you don't need it
this is another great reason to go get
vaccinated
now now yes
the vaccines are about saving your life
but also the lives of the people around
you
but they're also about helping you get
us get back to closer to normal in our
living
more normal living getting together with
friends
going to the park for a picnic without
needing to mask up
we're back to that place now as long as
you get vaccinated
so go get the shot go go go it's never
been easier
and once you're fully vaccinated you can
go without a mask
when you're outside and away from big
crowds
i want to thank the team at the cdc for
everything
they're doing to help us lead with
science and bring our communities out of
this crisis
safely and responsibly and i also want
to thank everyone
who's gotten the vaccine for doing your
patriotic duty
and helping us get on the path to
independence day
which i'll be discussing more in detail
next week right
in the meantime i urge all americans
don't let up now keep following the
guidance
go get your vaccination now
it's free and it's convenient
90 of the american people live within
five miles of a site where you can get a
vaccination
you can do this and we will do this
right thank you all and god bless you
and as much as the temptation is to stay
outdoors in this beautiful day
i've got more work to do thank you all
very very much
the risk is so low outdoors why doesn't
it apply to everybody
would you have any preconditions before
meeting with vladimir putin
i uh one at a time
if the risk is so low outdoors why
doesn't this new guidance apply to
everybody
because the science indicates that this
most certain way to make sure it doesn't
spread of both people
have been vaccinated the people you're
with and you're outside
and you chose to wear a mask sir you
chose to wear a mask you chose to wear a
mask as you walked out here
what message were you sending by wearing
a mask outside alone and watching me
take it off and not put it back on till
i get inside
wow do you have any preconditions before
meeting with vladimir putin
i'll discuss that all another day thank
you my
president will you make it faster to get
for them to get the vaccine the vaccines
we will get soon
india they're suffering what do you say
to the folks
i'm sorry i'm gonna just last question
i'll take and i said i'm really gonna be
in trouble
with regard to india i spoke at length
with modi
the prime minister we are sending
immediately
a whole series of help that he needs
including providing for those
rendez-severe and other drugs that are
able to deal with this and prevent in
some cases but
recover help recovery secondly
we are sending the actual
mechanical parts that are needed biden
putting the sunglasses on and then
dropping the hammer on that reporter was
pretty pretty good
and that's being done as well we're also
discussing
i've discussed with him when we'll be
able to send
actual vaccines to india which would be
my intention to do
the problem is right now we have to make
sure we have other vaccines like
novovacs and others coming on probably
and i think we'll be in a position to be
able to share
to share vaccines as well as know-how
with other countries who are in real
need
that's the hope and expectation and i
might add
when we were in a bind at the very
beginning india helped us thank you
sir what did you ask the vice president
to do to help with vaccine skepticism
there it is
joseph biden jr slipping on the
sunglasses and dropping the hammer on a
really stupid question from a reporter i
think that was peter alexander from nbc
news going by the voice
and the voice alone it was not peter
douchey but
um yeah quite a quite quite an
announcement so listen
i will be carrying my mask in my pocket
and if i
you know you go to a grocery store and
everybody's lined up outside
and if the grocery store asks that
people wear the mask in line
i'm gonna put the mask on of course you
know i'm not i'm not looking here to do
uh anything stupid but um i think that
the announcement makes a lot of sense
i see people saying won't the
anti-vaxxed people just lie about being
vaccinated you don't really have to lie
they'll just not wear their mask
nobody's going to be checking for
vaccination
really they are more at risk and even
with two unvaccinated people the outdoor
risk is extremely low
if the anti-vax people want to not wear
a mask
they probably already weren't wearing a
mask outdoors so i'm really not
uh not not worried about that
um okay
what a day what a day many states
outlining the path
out let's just very quickly
look at some of the data we are starting
to see
after this blip here we are starting to
see a case decline
that i am i'm not a betting man but i
would bet
accelerates dramatically over the next
three weeks as we get to
we are two and a half weeks from where
israel was
when their cases went skyrocketing
downward to quote donald trump um so i
think things are going to be looking
very good by
by memorial day and um
we just have to keep getting vaccinated
that's the that's that's the point
and i don't know by the way if people
have seen
what i mean if this this is what happens
when you vaccinate people look at this
it's it's basically zero um
really important stuff that's going on
so
we've got to start getting vaccines out
to different countries
and um we have to continue
doing the things that we've been doing
indoors or many of us have been doing
indoors
but it's definitely a good step forward
people are saying look at canada
i don't know what's going on in canada
uh yeah things aren't going so well in
canada okay
hopefully that's their last peak and
death starting to climb as well
yeah india i'm not even going to look at
because it's it's horrifying but joe
biden addressing that there and he's
going to
going to address it further all right
listen tomorrow night i will be here for
joe biden's
non-state of the union state of the
union we're starting at 8 pm eastern 5
p.m pacific
we will be here and we will have biden's
speech and we will have phone calls
and so many things all right so if
you're watching on twitch make sure
you're following if you're watching on
youtube make sure you're subscribed if
you're watching on facebook make sure
you've liked
so that tomorrow night you'll be
notified
when i go live alright see everybody
tomorrow night